[Applaudissements]
quel regard cette femme porte-t-elle sur
sa vie passée quand at-elle appris que
pourrait-elle en dire à ce jeune garçon
qui semble en attente de partager ces
expériences lui il débute sa vie il va
découvrir l'existence elle elle en écrit
les derniers chapitres et elle va être
invité à explorer la mort aurait-elle pu
me dire dans son dialecte
une phrase que j'ai si souvent entendu
et si on avait dit cette femme je vais
rencontrer en inde au coeur du temple de
fat pour six cris elle m'a offert son
regard a pris ma main dans la sienne la
serrer fortement me parlant avec ses
yeux avec une intensité que j'ai envie
de partager avec vous aujourd'hui elle
fait partie de ces rencontres qui change
une vie
lui c'est un enfants mendiants qui se
promenaient sur les routes qui mènent au
taj mahal ce lieu dédié à l'amour où les
richesses sont exposés au delà de la
mort alors comment pourrait-elle le
guider dans la construction sa
trajectoire de vie de quoi va-t-il avoir
besoin pour se construire
autant de questions que la femme médecin
ex pro à exploratrice la vie je me suis
posée au fil de mon parcours personnel
et professionnel
ces interrogations ont construit mon
histoire ont forgé mes rencontres et
m'ont amené à prendre soin aujourd'hui
d'un bien qui me semble très précieux et
même ça crée le lien les liens ce qui
nous unit ce qui nous construisent qui
parfois nous détruisent et sont amenés à
tuer ce qu'on va définir parfois de
toxic ou de libérateur au fond ces liens
il nous fabriquent ils nous façonnent
ils vont modeler le regard que l'on va
poser sur soi et sur les autres alors au
fil de ses explorations
j'ai fait une découverte j'ai découvert
une clé cette clé m'a ouvert de
nombreuses portes et j'ai envie de la
partager avec vous aujourd'hui
alors pour la découvrir j'ai cheminé au
fil de plusieurs étapes et je vais vous
inviter à suivre ces étapes avec moi la
première pierre qui commence notre
chemin et notre voyage l'intensité du
regard cette femme m'a témoigné nous
sommes tous reliés les uns aux autres au
delà des différences au delà de la
distance au delà de la langue
d'ailleurs les neurosciences nous le
disent nous sommes des êtres sociaux
les études sur le cerveau social nous
témoignent que nous sommes tous reliés
intrinsèquement reliés les uns aux
autres et même que notre survie notre
bien-être physique et psychologique
dépend de manière critique à la manière
dont nous avons construit les
interactions avec nos congénères
en d'autres temps certaine philosophie
on appelait ça l'interdépendance
alors voilà la première pierre est posée
la force du lien ce qui nous relie de
l'invisible au visible
sacré défi dans notre société alors
qu'elles vont nous faire de ce lien et
quelle qualité appelle-t-il vous avez vu
l'intensité du regard de cette maman qui
dévore son enfant des yeux j'aime
regarder ces regards
j'aime toucher la charge émotionnelle
qui nous témoignent à quel point ces
deux êtres sont reliés ce que vous avez
déjà remarqué comment les bébés nous
fascine même les bébés animaux
il arrive à nous arrêter dans notre
course folle il nous capte par la
présence la force de leur présence moi
je me rappelle d'un petit arthur il
arrivait planté dans sa poussette avec
sa maman pour une consultation
je n'ai pas pu commencer la consultation
sans le regarder marc était lui dire
bonjour
et puis je suis maire je suis la maman
de simon un grand gaillard d'aujourd'hui
21 ans qui est passionné de moto trial
et qui étudie l'architecturé et puis qui
nous avait invités à vivre dès le début
de la maternité
cette aventure est de nous faire
comprendre que c'est pas si facile de
construire les liens et que ça nous
invite à nous dépasser a dépassé nos
représentations
alors cette grossesse elle a débuté
après un long parcours d'infertilité
elle a été émaillée de complications
médicales et puis simon a décidé de
venir beaucoup plus tôt que prévu alors
sa venue était une joie infinie et puis
elle s'est teinté très vite d'une peur
d'une peur effroyable celui de le perdre
parce que le lien était déjà là si
intense et il semblait tenir à ces
perfusions et à ses soins médicaux si
prononcée et si envahissant comme un
oiseau tombé du nid comme ce père et son
fils que j'ai rencontré dans un parc à
new delhi il était là dans une clinique
qui s'occupait des oiseaux blessés
la femme était morte en couches et
prenez soin de son bébé alors j'ai
rencontré simon cinq jours après sa
naissance ce qu'il avait été transféré
avant même que je ne sois réveiller de
mon anesthésie générale
le père de simon m'a amené dans une
salle où il y avait quatre couveuse et
m'a présenté notre enfant j'ai découvert
cet intime inconnu cet enfant qui avait
été si vite arracher deux mois et je me
suis dit mais où est cet instinct dont
on m'a parlé et comment je vais
construire ce lien avec cet enfant dont
j'ai été déjà séparés si longtemps et
puis le premier regard et puis laventure
prend sens et vous que vous vous
rappelez du premiers instants du premier
regard avec votre enfant au moment où
c'est nos deux êtres se rencontrent au
de deux âmes se connecte comment c'est
irréel et comme si intense alors voilà
cette deuxième étape elle est là la
qualité de notre présence et nos enfants
nous invite à être plus présent à nous
mêmes plus présent à la vie
et quand j'accompagne aujourd'hui les
familles je me rends compte à quel point
nous avons beaucoup investi la grossesse
physique avec un suivi médical légitime
est important mais nous négligeons
souvent la grossesse psychique ce moment
qui est fondamental dans la construction
de la parentalité ses premiers pas vers
la construction de ce lien parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est aussi une sacrée
aventure que de rentrer dans la
maternité
comment être parent aujourd'hui dans une
société qui bouge
alors si on m'avait dit que la maternité
n'était pas toujours parsemée de bonheur
et que la peur pouvait être rendez vous
et si on m'avait dit que chaque instant
était comme un joyau à cultiver dès les
premiers regards dès les premières
années
si cruciale et puis je suis médecin
urgentiste puis généraliste avant de
devenir psychiatre avant de devenir
psychiatre
j'ai rencontré la souffrance comme j'ai
rencontré ces deux femmes dans les rues
d'accra
j'ai été formé à alléger la souffrance
j'ai été conditionnée à éviter la mort
qui m'a été présenté comme un échec de
notre mission de guérir et puis je suis
très soucieuse de la rigueur
scientifique qui est lié à ma profession
mais je me questionne aussi sur nos
modèles d'aujourd'hui qui parfois nous
limite dans la compréhension de l'humain
peut-être que nous devrions être invité
à plus d'humilité ou à plus de réserve
cantonaux quant à nos vérités alors
cette souffrance je me suis rendue
compte qu'elle venait impacté ce lien
que nos corps change est que nos visages
se modifiaient qu'il prenait des masques
et puis que certains comportements
évolué et puis je me demandais quelle
part cachée 7
individu va nous témoigner à travers ce
comportement parce que j'ai toujours eu
la curiosité d'aller au delà de ce qu'on
peut voir et au delà aussi pour nos
enfants et encore plus pour ces enfants
qui n'ont pas à kiel langage et pour
lequel leur cerveau est immature et puis
une rencontre encore plus essentielle a
changé ma vie
la rencontre avec la mort cette mort
pour rencontre sur les gâte de bénarès
cette mort qui m'a touché en tant que
femme avec le départ de mon beau fils et
de mes deux cousins qui ont décidé de
partir prématurément le décès de mon
beau-père qui nous a invités à découvrir
l'existence des expériences de mort
imminente
et puis la mort de tous ces patients que
j'ai accompagné jusqu'à leur dernière
étape et qui méritent des soins
appropriés et enfin le départ de ses
enfants pas encore nés dont j'accompagne
les parents chaque jour alors si on
m'avait dit que c'est en rencontrant la
mort que j'allais découvrir la vie et
que la qualité de la présence et sites
essentiels vous l'avez compris je suis
une exploratrice de la vie je suis
curieuse j'aime aller au delà de ce
qu'on peut voir
j'aime découvrir ce qui se passe
derrière au fil de ce chemin le lien la
présence
j'ai posé une troisième pierre j'ai
découvert qu'il y avait une émotion qui
s'insinuait dans nos vies de manière
beaucoup plus intense que nous le
pensions la peur la peur de perdre simon
la peur de la souffrance la peur de la
mort la peur de la peur qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas être un moteur de vie
alors que faisons nous de nos peurs
qu'elle prélassent prend-elle dans nos
vies et quels moyens nous avons pour les
réguler pour qu'elle continue à remplir
leurs missions et leurs fonctions de
nous protéger face aux dangers et au
delà de faire survivre l'espèce sans
nous figer nous paralyser nous empêchant
d'explorer c'est là que j'ai découvert
cette clé que je vais partager avec
cette clé nous dit que pour vivre
pleinement ce lien pour réguler nos
peurs pour être présent à la vie nous
avons tous un besoin fondamental le
besoin de sécurité émotionnelle
cette sécurité émotionnelle certains
auteurs la définissent comme un mets tu
as besoin comme un pré-requis comme une
condition sans laquelle nous ne pouvons
ou notre construction sera plus
compliqué sécurité terme si usitée dans
notre société où les guerres visibles et
invisibles envahissent nos écrans où la
violence est grandissante et où
l'insécurité nous questionnent temps
qu'elle soit professionnelle ou
économique
finalement pas étonnant qu'on soit dans
cette quête de sécurité
parce que cette sécurité c'est un
maillon fondamental de notre essence
d'être vivant alors comment j'ai croisé
comment j'ai découvert cette clé jeu
découverte parce qu'au fil de mes études
de mes lectures j'ai croisé une théorie
la théorie de l'attachement alors cette
théorie elle explique pas tout elle va
pas nous expliquer l'histoire d'un
individu comment il va se construire
dans son récit et dans son individualité
dans sa dimension intrapsychique mais
elle va nous inviter à éclairer ce qui
se passe dans ces liens dans ces liens
qui se tissent dans la manière dont nous
construisons nos relations
cette théorie elle nous dit que nous
avons tous à l'intérieur de nous un
système qui est inscrit dans notre
biologie et qui permet de réguler la
peur une fois que nous avons réguler nos
peurs nous sommes en capacité d'explorer
la vie de développer de nouvelles
connaissances et compétences de faire
face aux défis qu'elle nous présente
d'apprendre d'apprendre encore mieux de
découvrir cette théorie elle nous
explique que la manière de réguler nos
peurs va passer par la qualité du lien
que nous allons construire pendant les
premières années de vie par la qualité
de la présence des gens qui prennent
soin et des personnes qui prennent soin
de nous
enfant et par la qualité de
l'environnement dans lequel nous
grandissons qu'il soit affectif éducatif
ou sociétales cette théorie elle nous
apporte des connaissances
scientifiquement prouvé elles sont
validées elles sont évaluables cette
théorie a été appliquée dans d'autres
pays parce que eux ont décidé de se
questionner sur ce besoin fondamental de
l'enfant et de le remettre au coeur de
leurs préoccupations
alors elle va nous expliquer cette
théorie comment nous pouvons vivre nos
relations amicales nos relations
conjugales nos relations
professionnelles notre manière de
manager nos équipes mais moi j'ai décidé
de me pencher sur le berceau de la
relation qui relie les enfants à leurs
parents relation singulière unique et
éternel et ineffaçable qui nécessite
qu'on y pose une conscience appuyé parce
que cette théorie nous explique que ce
qui se passe dans les premières années
de vie c'est déterminant c'est pas
déterministe c'est déterminant dans la
mesure où nous ces années nous
permettent de construire une feuille de
route sur laquelle nous allons nous
appuyer pour pouvoir évoluer et
construire une relation alors sans nous
culpabiliser mais en ou responsabilisant
quelle sécurité offrons-nous aujourd'hui
à nos enfants
comment nous organisons notre quotidien
aujourd'hui est-ce que la compétition où
la performance qui est attendu de nous
ne vient pas impacter notre présence
notre présence à eux
est ce que quand nous réorganisons nos
vies parce que nous avons des événements
de vie ou des choix qui nous oblige à
repenser les choses
nous pensons alors besoin de sécurité
fondamentale est-ce que les juges qui
s'occupe des gardes d enfants sont
formés à cette théorie de l'attachement
est ce que quand nous confions nos
enfants à l'école
nous avons conscience de la multi s'y
plie de la multiplicité des
professionnels qui s'occupent de nos
enfants les insécurisant peut-être pas
si étonnant qu'ils aient de la violence
qui arrive y compris dans les cours des
petites écoles
et puis la protection de l'enfance
les parcours nous que nous que nous
offrons à ces enfants et qui nous
questionnent de manière fondamentale
les mises en applications sont multiples
et finalement au delà dans jeu
individuel c'est réellement un enjeu
sociétal que cette théorie questionne et
que cette conscience du lien nous invite
à visiter
alors voilà le voyage se termine
j'aimerais penser que si chacun de nous
avions plus conscience de ce besoin de
sécurité émotionnelle de nos enfants de
nous mêmes de nos proches des êtres que
nous rencontrons peut-être que nous
pourrions poser un autre regard sur
l'autre pour aller au delà de la
méfiance au delà des comportements que
nous décodons pas toujours pour dépasser
nos peurs qui nous transforme parfois en
ont ou en fantôme traversant la vie sans
avoir conscience des richesses qu'elle
nous offre pour retrouver la joie d'être
ensemble
comme ces regard espiègle de ce vieil
homme et de cette petite fille qui nous
disent à quel point la présence à
l'autre est essentielle et puis pour
nous dire qu'il ya une vision plus
grande qui nous attend alors peut-être
que vous allez l'a rencontré dans le
premier regard que vous croiserez en
sortant de ses conférences
[Applaudissements]